hey ihr kleinen schleckermäulchen wenn
wir meinen kanal schon etwas länger
kennt wisst ihr dass ich eine sache ganz
schön gerne mag ja okay das auch aber
ich spreche von harry potter harry
potter riesch mary potter nachdem james
1997 den ersten band herausbrachte
vergingen ein paar jahre 23 und der
schinken hat sich seitdem über 500
millionen mal verkauft fast so oft wie
mainz
wir brauchen nicht darüber sprechen ob
und wie uns die buchreihe gefällte denn
das wäre so als ob wir uns fragten wir
uns denn gutes wetter ein lottogewinn
oder das ende von corona gefallen würde
die antwort ist klar allerdings spalten
sich bei den filmen ein wenig die
geister aber da ich kein hort kurs super
mega heavy metal superkraft potter had
been so wie kelly juckt mich die kritik
nicht und ich mag die filme wie sie sind
und nun kommen wir auch schon zum
zweiten teil harry potter und die kammer
des schreckens ich werde jetzt nichts
zur handlung sagen dann sind wir mal
ehrlich in spin twenty years ich fasse
mich deshalb kurz harry stein menschen
tagebuch kammer schlange schwer phoenix
tobi ende und dazwischen passiert etwas
richtig super mega spannendes tante
petunia macht eine sahnetorte denn der
herr im haus mister darcy bekommt besuch
von einem der in ein paar tore abkaufen
möchte und die torte hat so einen
komischen look und eine noch seltsamere
materialbeschaffenheit wenn ich das hier
so sagen kann dass ich richtig an
sie zu machen beste voraussetzung also
viel spaß bei vanessa und die torte des
schreckens denen der in den winter
ich weiß ich eigentlich schon alles im
intro erwähnt aber weil ich es so lange
nicht mehr gesagt habe hallo leute ich
es wieder eure mal wann und wie kann man
zu einer neuen folge wie schmeckt und
heute machen wir die torte aus dem film
harry potter und die kammer des
schreckens
das hat sich gut angefühlt ich habe mich
lange vor dieser torte gedrückt weil ich
noch nie die see gemacht habt bb b ccc
cc c heißt kurs auf französisch gerade
kleine küssel und man braucht nur eiweiß
zucker wir sind seit das verrühren und
im backofen das bisher auf der torte
sieht wirklich so schön geschlagen aus
und ich echte herausforderung und
ansonsten habe ich eigentlich nur sahne
cocktail kirchen und was ich heute
entdeckt habe lila blumen und das habe
ich natürlich auch noch nie gemacht aber
wir kriegen ja alles hin am schlafen wir
beginnen mit dem www denn der muss drei
stunden ofen backen wir haben vier
schichten die unterste schicht ist die
größte und dann kommt drei kleine
obendrauf kühne ein kreis
angreifen angreifen
und jetzt wo wir alles vorbereitet haben
fangen wir an mit der zubereitung wir
besitzen acht eier für drei eier nimmt
der 180 gramm zucker wie viel zucker
brauchen wir für acht eier die rechnung
ist natürlich ganz klar ein ei bedeutet
60 gramm zucker das bedeutet 60 x 8 sind
480 g 8 eiweiß 480 gramm zucker und zehn
tropfen zitronensaft für die tropfen
zitronensaft die wir brauchen
testen jetzt mal einen tick tock dafür
stechen mir ein loch in eine seite und
einlochen andere seite
ich halte jetzt schon mal den ofen auf
100 grad auf weil ich glaube das muss
schnell den gleichschritt 1 eier trennen
[Musik]
ach komm ich mache gleich alles kommen
leute wir machen gleich alles acht eier
[Musik]
was macht man auch eine creme brulée ich
vorne machten den meiner kirchencafé
[Applaus]
unser eiweiß ist nun getrennt und nun
wiegen wir ein halbes kilo zucker ab
alter ist das viel zucker schritt nummer
18 prisen salz ins eiweiß geben schritt
2 aufschlagen
achso und letztes mal war ein bisschen
nervös takt meine haare nach hinten
keine sorge und jetzt ist es soweit
geworden nun können wir anfragen den
zucker dazugeben
jetzt sitzt die masse schön cremig und
wenn sie so cremig ist soll man das hier
dazugeben ok und weiter schlagen
nun müssen die eier masse irgendwie in
diese form reinkriegen und dafür
brauchen wir spritzbeutel denen hier
nehmen wir der macht so schön den rand
aus dass jetzt rein und dann stark und
dann im ofen gibt es viel zu voll
gemacht wie das foyer form helfen vor
begeisterten so sieht's aus das bewegt
sich kein stück ich bin begeistert ich
werde jetzt mal den mail nehmen damit es
bei dem zweiten mich daran klebt weiter
von bagdad gebracht hat
bei dem großen bin ich mal gespannt ob
das fest wird aber ich kann mir das
schon recht gut vorstellen ich glaube
die wird ein bisschen kleiner zu sorgen
also jetzt soll man das auch in den ofen
und auf 75 grad eine stunde okay wir
sind zwei stunden hier süßen ich hab
mich gerade schon gefreut dass ich ja
jetzt quasi frei habe und dann ist mir
eingefallen dass wir diese blumen machen
müssen für unsere deko blumen brauchen
wir neue leißing denn das kann in der
luft trocknen und hat kein salmonellen
kein salmonellen ist gut ihr könnt
natürlich auf anderes verwenden ich habe
jetzt gerade das noch zu hause
natürlich habe ich jetzt profi auch lila
lebensmittelfarbe hören dann müssen wir
das versuchen wir blumen daraus zu
machen und können wir mal an dieser
stelle tante petunia ein bisschen drops
geben
ich meine was hat sie eine krasse torte
gemacht aber kein wunder dass onkel
vernon dann so fett ist wenn sie seine
musik horten macht wir brauchen 125
gramm racing und 15 milliliter wasser
und das kommt in den mixer
wie soll ich mir das nicht vorgestellt
mit schwarz dunkler werden das bekommt
genau den faden wir brauchen unsere
blüten passt ist jetzt fertig und daraus
können wir jetzt welche formeln da
brauchen wir jetzt nochmal unseren
spritzbeutel jetzt gerade so viel lila
um mich herum unglaublich um solche
blumen kreieren zu können ist so ein
flacher aufsatz praktisch herbst noch
nie gemacht
es kann auch eine deshalb mache in den
spritzbeutel vielleicht wenn ich einfach
so machen das ist auch nicht schön
das sieht aus wie eine blume ich mach
mal weiter und zeigt euch gleich das
ergebnis 2000 jahre später
und hier sind sie manche sind gar nicht
so schlecht geworden und dafür andere
neue aber natürlich hat es da noch nicht
auf wir müssen noch die kleinen gelben
punkte machen dafür packen wir unseren
rest in eine schüssel und färben ist mit
[Musik]
farbe ist doch schön sehr auffällig und
zwischendurch mal den ofen aufmachen um
die feuchtigkeit rauslassen unser sprits
gerät ist perfekt dafür viel zu viel zu
viel
dort ist noch ein fertig die sehen
vielleicht gerade noch nicht so gut aus
weil sie diesen negativen cheerleader
effekt haben also in der gruppe sehen
sie hässlich aus aber einzelne
schönheiten sind dabei und damit ist tag
eins geschafft und wir sehen uns jetzt
wieder aber für mich ist es dann einen
tag später schweizer daten wie sie ist
fertig und unsere blumen getrocknet
nervt euch auch wie rufus beck snape
spricht sehr zu
ich selbst sind sie sich bruce lee sie
schneiden die wurzel für malfoy
ich habe ihn mir nie vorgestellt mit so
einem akt sind das budget sollte über
nacht im backofen chillen und ich weiß
nicht ob's geworden ist
ich glaube ich krieg das doch nicht
runter tortenboden number one in serbien
ist einfach auf dem boden boden nummer
zwei und boden nummer drei und vier akio
laptop jetzt müssen wir mal wieder die
torte analysieren und zwar sehen wir
zwei verschiedene seine farben einmal
lavendel und mintgrün und auf der oberen
schicht kann man noch so eine weiße
creme entdecken und diese sahne bisschen
wir machten vor das ist voll kompliziert
ich habe hier so ein pulver und ich
glaube das eignet sich sehr gut um seine
einzufärben weil die darf nicht zu viel
feuchtigkeit flüssigkeit von anderen
produkten kriegen grünen brauchen wir
blau brauchen wir und violett hama und
dann brauchen wir natürlich sagen und
damit meine sahne steif bleibt
sahnesteif ich habe im internet gelesen
dass man seine schüssel vorher in den
kühlschrank machen soll damit wie schön
kalt ist das habe ich getan und da
packen wir jetzt unsere sahne hinein
wir machen erstmal zwei wenn ich einmal
zu haben und racke dann kann man sie
nicht mehr rückgängig machen und da habe
ich so ein von susanne wird jetzt
aufgeschlagen und während ist schnee
soll man das reinhören und dann kommt
noch tomkat sogar mit echter vanille
rein
was macht so ein bisserl zu verein und
jetzt aufschlagen pause und lila heimat
ist das schöne lebens meine farbe man
habe jetzt nochmal lebensmittelfarbe
reingemacht andere also die sagen da
nicht schlecht aus es gibt sie auch
langsam die farbe ja übrigens man den
spaß in so ein einweg spritzbeutel packe
ich jetzt so eine spitze rein und kehrte
so nach vorne
dann wird hier oben so abgeschnitten
dann haben sie eine spritzfahrt spitze
und dann kommt unsere wunderschönen
sahne da rein
die sieht so gut aus ich möchte aus und
gar nicht enttäuscht
und das kommt jetzt belegen rein kommen
wir zusammen nummer 2 und dieses mal
werden wir nicht verkaufen wir brauchen
wieder eine gekühlte schüssel und
natürlich sahne und noch mehr sahne und
dann einen mixer und danach steigt
und grünen lebensmittels habe ich weiß
ist das steife same auf jeden fall für
mir das ganz schön rein da luz die sich
schon ein bisschen besser gelungen
zugunsten bodysuit stolz und da wir
jetzt den schlimmsten teil hinter uns
haben und die samen im kühlschrank auch
ins wasser kommen wir jetzt zum dorian
und ich muss sagen die farben von man
spritzt hüten sind exzellent
ich habe meine rosen vergesst die
blümchen die dürfen wir natürlich nicht
vergessen
wir fangen an mit einer schicht rich and
green i frosting oha das ist das zeug
aus geoffrey star einfach nur löffelt
oha baby so damit mache ich jetzt eine
schicht wolle auf die erste schicht
trotzdem kommt jetzt noch sahne damit
sie ein bisschen höher steht
allerdings vermutet dann machen wir ein
paar grüne stritten wir wissen nicht was
da drin verliert ok dann kommt jetzt
unsere schicht drauf im nächsten schritt
brauchen wir große lila pöppel und
dazwischen zur grüne jobs ließ cook kein
freund utah
okay man am ende muss es von einer seite
schön aussehen geschichte kommt jetzt
nach frosting soll ich eben vergessen so
und jetzt müssen wir das andere reverse
machen also große grüne block pilz und
dann dazwischen kleine lila oder flut
geworden
das ist unsere letzte play com
jetzt dürfen wir das frosting weiter
nach außen verteilt denn dort sieht man
es ja eine schicht ist bei uns
untergegangen und auch die langen
unteren kommt jetzt jeweils eine blume
ein bisschen zu groß
na ja und warum mein gott die wie so gut
aus jetzt kommt das große finale
die großen sahne scheißhaufen drauf und
natürlich sieht man wir tun ja nicht wie
sie die ganze torte macht sondern nur
wie sie die tische dekoriert ich habe
hier kaiser kirchen genommen ich glaube
sie hat kock kirschen aber cognition
sind wirklich schwer zu finden in
deutschland und deswegen verklagt nicht
und der letzte schritt die kirchen
zwischen die lilien blockes schalt dein
name
und nun stellen wir uns wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage was wird kelly
der größte potter hat den ich in meinem
leben kenne so dieser torte sagt karl
josef wirges harry potter fährt eine
inselwelt what do you say to main uk und
wenn wir uns wirklich die
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckte die
torte aus harry potter und die kammer
des schreckens wir stellen uns eher die
frage wie schneidet man so eine torte an
ok ich lasse euch daran teilhaben
so sieht unsere torte vom internet aus
sahne und zucker
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob ich es hasse oder
liebe ich finde ich auch ein bisschen
zuviel crossing verwendet aber weil das
budget so zerbrechlich ist wollte ich
halt dann zu sehr um ihre liebe hat wie
sie die neue aber bitte probieren
das ist die tore wieder übertrieben groß
ist diese bund dies irgendwie nett und
geile übertrieben posten des wie
explosiv
also die zürcher aber extrem geil was
für die nächsten tage die stiftung
warentest sagt ja diese torte schmeckt
sehr süß und man würde jetzt nicht so
viel davon essen aber sie passt auch
perfekt zu ihm dürfen wenn ihr noch
weitere vorschläge habt was ich denn mal
bei ihm schmeckt's kochen soll schreibt
mir das gerne in die kommentare
ich freue mich auf jeden vorschlag und
tut mir den gefallen wenn ihr etwas habt
schreibt vielleicht auch in welcher
folge ist vorkommt oder in welcher
staffel weil dann finde ich es schneller
und muss mich jede folge durchschauen
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
eure mal wanne